many Americans went to bed shocked by
the deaths in El Paso and walk on Sunday
to news of another mass shooting this
time Dayton Ohio nine dead more than 20
wounded the shooter killed as well he'd
walked through a busy area packed with
bars and nightclubs firing
indiscriminately we don't know the
thoughts of the shooter at this time we
know that he was wearing body armor and
high-capacity magazines and extra
magazines right now our focus is on the
families and friends frankly that went
to went to town town on a Saturday night
and thought that they'd go home safe and
that didn't happen the president has
ordered all flags across the u.s. to fly
at half-staff until sunset on Thursday
in memory of those killed and he praised
the response of local law enforcement
hate has no place in our country and
we're gonna take care of it I spoke with
attorney general bill Barr at length I
spoke to Christopher a director of the
FBI spoke to the governor's both
governor's and we're doing a lot of work
a lot of people are working right now a
lot of law enforcement people and others
spoke to members of Congress about
whatever we can do we have to get it
stopped this has been going on for years
the man being held for the El Paso
shooting is a 21 year old white male
police and federal authorities are
trying to confirm if he posted a racist
anti-immigrant anti-hispanic street to
an extremist web site just hours before
the shooting one Democratic presidential
candidate Beto O'Rourke who comes from
El Paso says the president bears a
responsibility for that shooting the
president's language his rhetoric has
produced the kinds of hate crimes that
we saw in El Paso yesterday but we've
been seeing across this country they've
been on the rise for each one of the
last three years so we cannot act as
though this were just some kind of
natural disaster or a matter of course
for this country or the new normal for
the United States but the president's
chief of staff dismissed that idea I
don't think it's fair to try and lay
this at the feet of the president I did
there are people in this
country this morning thinking the
president Trump was was happy by this
that's a sad sad state of this nation
he's angry he's upset he wants it to
stop I don't think it's at all fair to
sit here and say that that he doesn't he
doesn't think that white nationalism is
bad for the nation Deaton and El Paso
are no different changed forever part of
the list of places in America where
they've suffered experienced lived
through mass shootings and with a
presidential election 15 months away
changing America's gun laws may become
part of the bigger conversation Allen
Fisher al Jazeera